President Obama this week announced that
we're going to do a review group
designed to assess the nation's
intelligence and surveillance gathering
practices and who did he assign to put
the gang together well he went with
James clapper you may remember James
clapper from this so what I wanted to
see is if you could give me a yes or no
answer to the question does the NSA
collect any type of data at all on
millions or hundreds of millions of
Americans no sir it does not not
wittingly there are cases where they
could inadvertently perhaps collect but
not not wittingly okay I I really love
that video because you remember the
episode of Seinfeld when they talked
about how if you're lying the more
you're lying the higher up on your face
you're touching he's literally
scratching his scalp off he scratched on
the top of his head off there so that's
James clapper who is the director of
national intelligence and that him is
live there is he is lying to Congress
and to all of us so of course he's the
guy that's gonna head the group that's
gonna watch dog the thing is this just
again I mean this sort of is like the
previous topic but is this cool could
get away with this but the government I
like the idea of an accidental spy like
oh we have all this information we
didn't get our purpose yeah we like all
look at this we happen to have it right
the word unwittingly well not only using
perhaps you know the things that are
like questionable I'm okay so maybe is
that what you're saying or maybe doing
this but I'm not really choose this guy
how does he doesn't it seem like such a
slap in the pit we're gonna take the guy
who just lied to you and you all know he
lied so here we go are you surprised
though because I'm no sadly no I'm not
in the least because i thought you know
i was in 2012 or 2011 there was that
expansion of the Patriot Act put in
place by Obama and I thought hmm this is
not a nap in the advent of the the
Snowden and all of this being found out
in terms of hey look you're a big fat
greek irmak I was gonna say Greek liar
but you're making that life by a creek
he's not great yeah don't have heard
that play on words doesn't work anymore
but yeah so with the combination of two
things being that Obama's
office and he's deliberately extended
that the scope and the power of the
Patriot Act yeah and then this being
found out i'm not surprised that you'd
put he has a conflict of interest now
that because the public is aware of it i
have to conduct an investigation well
who's gonna investigate this in the
least beneficial way returning to it the
guy that lied to everybody's faces yeah
so does this go to like the problem with
obama sort of is that we all still want
to like him like even the way you just
said that there's this feeling like oh
he plays basketball he seems to kind of
like weed right you know it immediately
and beyond say so we all kind of why
like him so even when he does stuff like
this there's this feeling of like well
can't really be Obama's fault even
though he did it right it's not like you
don't want to admit okay if it's not
Obama's fault then there are people
there just walking all over this guy
that's like this is what we're gonna do
is it the rock Harry part yeah yeah you
know scary but right if he's not in
charge then who is it now really
slightly off down here but it becomes
clear like when this guy's put in charge
the only purpose of this group is for
that guy to say would not you can't say
it like that no that's not information
you can put out there no you're gonna
have to look a little harder like if
anybody actually finds any real
information of wrongdoing that guy is
that's the guy who's getting fired yeah
it is there to say well I'm not gonna be
on this report yeah nope he's gonna go
well you know wittingly we can't put
that in this report those old-fashioned
redacted files where you see everything
is black stout activity hello and the
dates and it's like yeah that that's
exactly what's going to be found there's
nothing here yeah of course in a
redacted file there's nothing so is that
part of it then that even if they had
chosen someone that was respected that
we already all know the outcome of this
they're not gonna change anything right
i mean though obama was on leno last
week saying we don't spy on americans
but pretty much everything that i've
seen since then says the complete
reverse and i think it's you know maybe
we don't want to know maybe it's them
assuming that the American people don't
actually want to know really yeah and if
someone if there was really an impartial
if there was a way to find someone who
is truly a partial who would really
delve into this thoroughly and actually
reveal hey these are the findings it
would be terrifying because it would be
like oh my god
about me and you know and maybe it would
create widespread panic and that's the
rationale to just let's just we'll just
put the appearance and we're gonna
investigate but we're gonna make it so
that you're not really expecting an
answer right right I pretty much believe
what you just said that I believe that
to be true that they just have to keep
sort of lying to us at the delay is so
big that they just kinda have to keep
lying otherwise the whole the whole
house of cards falls but is that kind of
sad that America has gotten a sad but
even a best-case scenario yeah you know
that if somebody completely independent
is put in charge and they're like look
at all this stuff we found then whoever
doesn't want them to find that out will
be able to say we'll look at all this
stuff that we have on you from when we
were spying exactly maybe you don't want
to put it out that is the huge part that
nobody's willing to talk about the chill
effect of this whole thing is that
everybody has watched porn right right
and not saying you're watching illegal
porn of any kind but everyone married
people are watching porn without their
wife knowing so now you get this guy duh
you know what I mean and then he's gonna
be like oh I guess everything's okay you
know it looks fine or i have this file
on you well we have this file on you
naughty nurses 80 i don't have this file
on you yeah it's exactly man we are
truly becoming a philip k dick novel in
this in this country